today what we're gonna be doing is we're
gonna be starting to talk about fast
reinforcement learning so in terms of
where we are in the class we've just
finished up policy search you guys are
working on policy gradient right now for
your homework and then that'll be the
last homework and then the rest of the
time will be on projects and then right
now we're gonna start to talk about fast
reinforcement learning which is
something that we haven't talked about
so much so so the things we've discussed
a lot so far in the term are things like
optimization generalization and delayed
consequences so how do we do planning a
Markov decision processes how do we
scale up to really large state spaces
using like deep neural networks and how
do we do this optimization and I think
that that works really well for a lot of
cases where we have good simulators or
where data is pretty cheap but a lot of
the work that I do in my own lab thinks
about how do we teach computers to help
us which naturally involves
reinforcement learning because we're
teaching computers about how to make
decisions that would help us but I think
there are a lot of other applications
where we'd really like computers to help
us so things like education or
healthcare or consumer marketing and
each of these cases we can think of them
as being reinforcement learning problems
because we'd have some sort of agent
like our computer that is making
decisions as it interacts with a person
and it's trying to optimize some reward
like it's trying to help someone learn
something or it's trying to treat a
patient or it's trying to increase
revenue for a company by having
consumers click on ads and in all of
those cases the place where data comes
from is people and so there's at least
two big challenges with that the first
is that you know people are finite
there's not an infinite number of people
and also that it's expensive and costly
to try to gather data when you interact
with people and so it raises the concern
about sample efficiency so in general of
course we would love to have
reinforcement learning algorithms that
are both computationally efficient and
sampling
but most of the techniques we've been
looking at so far particularly the sort
of q-learning
type techniques we're really sort of
inspired by this need for computational
efficiency so if we think back to when
we were just were doing planning at the
beginning when we talked about doing
dynamic programming versus doing queue
learning in dynamic programming we had
to do a sum over all next States and in
TD learning we sampled that so in TV
learning we sort of had this constant
cost per update versus for dynamic
programming we had this s squared times
a cost so it was much more expensive to
do things like dynamic programming than
it was to do TD learning on a per step
basis and so a lot of the techniques
would have been developed in
reinforcement learning have really been
thinking about this computational
efficiency issue and there are a lot of
times for competition efficiency is
important like if you wanted to plan
from scratch and you were sort of
driving a car at 60 miles per hour then
if it takes you so if you're driving a
car at 60 miles per hour and it takes to
your computer one second to make a
decision about like you know how to turn
the wheel or something like that
then during that one second you've
traveled you know many feet so in a lot
of cases you really do have real time
constraints on the computation you can
do and in many situations like for you
know in the cases of some robotics and
particularly when we have simulators
we really want computational efficiency
because we need to be able to do these
things very quickly we can sort of use
our simulators but we need our
simulators to be faster our agent can
learn in contrast to those sort of
examples or things where a sample
efficiency is super expanded to maybe
computation is less important
so whenever experience is costly or hard
together and
particularly things that involve people
so we think about students or patients
or customers the way that our agent will
learn about the world is making
decisions and that data affects real
people so it might be very reasonable
for us to take you know several days of
computation if we could figure out a
better way to treat cancer because we
don't want to randomly experiment on
people and we want to use the data as
well as we can and be really really
sample efficient versus in the case of
like the Atari it's we want to be really
computationally efficient because we can
do many many simulations it's fine no
one's getting hurt
but but we need to eventually learn to
make you know to drive a good game so
one natural question might be okay so
maybe now we care about sample
efficiency and before we cared perhaps
more about computational efficiency but
maybe the algorithms we've already
discussed are already sample efficient
so does anybody remember like on the
order of magnitude or like you know
somewhere in the rough ballpark how many
steps it took DQ and to learn a good
policy for pong maybe multiple answers
maybe somewhere party between two to ten
is my guest to ten million so that's a
lot that's a lot of data to learn to
play pong so I would argue that the
techniques we've seen so far are not
going to address this issue and it's not
going to be reasonable for us to need
you know somewhere between two to ten
million customers before we figure out a
good way to target ads or two to ten
million patients before we figure out
the right decisions to do so the
techniques we've seen so far are not
going to be there formally not sample
efficient and they're also empirically
not sample efficient so we're gonna need
new types of techniques than what we've
seen so far so of course when we start
to think about this we think about the
general issue of you know what does it
mean for an algorithm to be good we've
talked about computational efficiency
and I've mentioned this thing called
sample efficiency but in general I think
one thing we care a lot about is you
know how good is our reinforcement
learning algorithm and we're
start to try to quantify that in terms
of sample efficiency but of course you
could have an algorithm that's really
sample efficient in the sense that maybe
it only uses the first ten data points
and then it never updates its policy so
it doesn't need very much data to find a
policy but the policy is bad so when we
talk about sample efficiency we're gonna
want both that we don't need very much
data and that we don't need very much
data in order to make good decisions so
we still want to get good performance we
just don't need want to need very much
experience to get there so when we talk
about what it means for an algorithm to
be good you know why not one possibility
is we can talk about whether or not it
converges at all
that just means whether or not the value
function or the policies is stable at
some point like asymptotically because
the number of time steps goes to
infinity and we talked about how
sometimes with a value function
approximation we don't even have that
like things can oscillate then another
thing that stronger the night that you
might want is to say well asymptotically
as T goes to infinity will we converge
to the optimal policy and we talked
about some algorithms that would do that
under some different assumptions but
what we haven't talked about very much
is sort of you know well how quickly do
we get there
asymptotically is a very long time and
so we might want to be able to say if we
have two algorithms and one of them gets
the optimal policy here like if this is
performance this is time and another
algorithm goes like this intuitively
algorithm two is better than algorithm
one even though they both get to the
optimal policy eventually so we'd like
to be able to sort of account for either
we can think about things like how many
mistakes our algorithm makes or its
relative performance over time compared
to the optimal and so we'll start to
talk today about some other forms of
measures for how good an algorithm is so
in this lecture in the next couple of
lectures we're gonna do several
different things trying to talk about
sort of how good are these reinforcement
learning algorithms and think about
algorithms that could be much better in
terms of their guarantees for
performance
we're going to start off and talk about
tabular settings back today we're only
going to talk about simple bandits but
generally for the next today and next
lecture we'll talk about tabular
settings and then hopefully also get to
some about function approximation plus
sample efficiency but we'll start to
talk about through settings frameworks
and approaches so the settings that
we're gonna be covering like today and
next time is going to be bandits which a
number of you who here is doing the
default project okay so a number of you
are already starting to think about this
in terms of the project so we'll
introduce bandits today and then we'll
also talk about this for mdps
and then we'll also introduce frameworks
and these are evaluation criteria for
formally assessing the quality of a
reinforcement learning algorithm so
they're way they're sort of a tool you
could use to evaluate many different
algorithms and algorithms will either
satisfy this framework or not or have
different properties under these
different frameworks and then we'll also
start to talk about approaches which are
classes of algorithms for achieving
these different evaluation criteria or
these different frameworks in different
settings either for the MDP setting or
or for the bandit setting and what will
shortly see is that there's a couple
main ideas of styles that are approaches
of algorithms which turn out to both
have be applicable both to bandit
settings and MDP settings and function
approximation actually and also that
have some really nice formal properties
there's sort of a couple big conceptual
ideas about how we might do fast
reinforcement learning okay so the plan
for today will be that we'll first start
with an introduction to multi-year
methods then we'll talk about the
definition of regret on a mathematical
formal sense and then we'll talk about
optimism under uncertainty and then as
we can we'll talk about Bayesian regret
and probability matching and Thompson
sampling I'm curious who here has ever
seen this sort of material before okay a
couple people most people not I wouldn't
I is it covered in a I don't think they
would cover it
all right so for some of you I will be a
review for most of you it'll be new so
for multi armed bandits we can think of
them as a subset of reinforcement
learning so it's generally considered a
set of arms that there's a set of em
arms which were the equivalent to what
we used to call actions so in
reinforcement learning in our set of
actions we think of like they're being M
different actions now we're often going
to call those arms and then for each of
those arms they have distribution of
rewards you could get so we haven't
talked a lot about sort of having
uncertainty over our rewards we've
mostly just talked about the expected
reward and for multi-on bandits today
we're gonna explicitly think about the
fact that rewards might be sampled from
a stochastic distribution so there's
some distribution that we don't know
which is conditioned on the arm so
conditioned on the arm you're gonna get
different rewards so for example it
could be that for our one your
distribution looks something like this
this is the probability of that reward
and this is rewards and then forearm two
it looks something like this so in this
particular example the average reward
for arm one would be higher than the
average award for arm two and then they
would have different variances but it
doesn't have to be Gaussian you could
have lots of different distributions
essentially what we're trying to capture
here is that whenever you take a
particular action which we also refer to
as pulling an arm for the multi-armed
bandit then the reward you get might
vary even if you pulled the same arm
twice so in this case you can imagine
that if you pull the arm once and one
once you might get a reward here and
maybe the second time you'd get a reward
there so the idea in this case is it
similar to mdps except for now there's
no transition function so there's no
state or equivalently you can think of
it as there's only a single state and so
when you take an arm you stay in the
same state there's always these M
actions available to you and on each
step you get to pick what action to take
and then you observe some
that is sampled from the unknown
probability distribution associated with
that arm and just like in reinforcement
learning we don't know what those reward
distributions are in advance and our
goal is to maximize the cumulative
reward so if someone told you what these
distributions were in advance you would
know exactly which arm to pull whichever
one has the highest expected as expected
mean so we're going to try to use pretty
similar notation to what we had for the
reinforcement learning case but if you
notice things that are confusing and
just let me know so we're gonna define
the action value as the mean reward for
a particular action so that's Q a this
is unknown agent doesn't know this in
advance the optimal value B star is
going to be equal to Q of the best
action and then the regret is going to
be the opportunity loss for one step so
what that means is that if instead of
taking if you could have taken Q of a
star and instead you took Q of a T so
this is the actual arm you selected how
much in expectation did he lose by
taking the suboptimal arm and this is
how we're going to mathematically define
regret in the case of reinforcement
learning so if you selected the optimal
arm you're regret we expected to regret
will be zero for that time step but for
any other arm there will be some loss
and the total regret is just the total
opportunity loss if you sum over all the
time steps that the agent acts and
compare the actions it took and the
expected reward of each of those actions
to the expected reward of the optimal
action so just to be clear here this is
not known this is not known to the agent
and this is unknown to the agent just
check for understanding for a second why
is this so why is the second thing
unknown to the agent right so what is
right so you don't know what the
distribution is so you don't know what
queue is you get to observe a sample
from that so you get to observe our you
get to get an R which was sampled from
the probability distribution over words
given the action that was taken but you
don't get to observe either the true
expected value of the optimal arm nor
the true expected value of the arm that
you selected so this isn't something we
can normally evaluate unless we're in a
simulated domain but we're going to talk
about ways that we can bound this and
think about algorithms that try to
minimize the regret so if we think about
ways to sort of quantify it another way
to think about it alternatively is that
think about the number of times that you
take a particular action we can call
that NT of a so that's like the number
of times we select action 1 action 2 etc
and then we can define a gap which is
the difference between the optimal arms
value and the value of the arm that we
selected and that's the gap so that's
how much we lost by picking a different
arm than the optimal arm so this gap is
equal to gap for a star is equal to 0
because you don't lose anything by
taking the optimal arm and for all other
arms it's going to be positive so
another way to think about the regret
which is equivalent is to say this is
equivalent to thinking about what are
the expected number of times you you
select each of the arms times their gap
so how much you would lose by selecting
that arm compared to the optimal arm and
what we would like is that sort of an
algorithm I should be able to adjust how
many times you pull arms which have
large gaps so if there's a really really
bad arm like there's really bad action
which has a very low reward you would
like not to pull that as much to take
that action as much as the arms that are
close to optimal
so one approach that we've seen before
is greedy in the case of bandits the
greedy algorithm is very simple we just
average the the rewards we've seen for
an arm
so we just look at every single time
that we took that arm we look at the
reward we got for each of those time
stamps and then we average it and that
just gives us I'm an estimate of the of
Q hat and then what greedy does is it
selects the action with the highest
value and takes that arm forever so it's
probably clear in this case that because
the rewards are sampled from a
stochastic distribution that if you are
unlucky and get samples that are
misrepresentative then you could lock
into the wrong action and stay there
forever so if we think of that little
example I gave before and I'll work out
a bigger example shortly so in this case
imagine this is reward this is
probability and this was a 2 so let's
imagine that the first and I don't know
make this 1 and this 0 so if you sample
from a 1 in this case you could imagine
there's some nonzero probability that
the first sample you get is say 0.2 for
a 1 and the first sample you get for a 2
with nonzero probability might be 0.5 so
the true mean of a 2 is lower than the
mean of a 1 but if you sampled each of
these once then if you're a greedy with
respect to that then you would take the
wrong action for other action forever is
the idea that our policy is going to be
influencing what's am still get in the
future or is IDIA but but there are some
set of samples independent of this
treaty policy to begin because it would
seem otherwise if there's non 0 board
you just take that one forever great
question so it's yes so what said is you
know is there an additional thing that
we're doing kind of before this normally
for a lot of these algorithms and we're
going to assume that all of them operate
by selecting each arm what's at least if
you have a finite set of arms and
equivalently you can say if you don't
have any data you treat everything
equivalently or but is
most of these ones say until you have
data for all the arms we're gonna do
round-robin you're gonna sample
everything once and after you do that
either you can be greedy or we can do
something else so there has to be a pre
initialization phase it's a good
question so and we're also going to
assume for right now that we split ties
with equal probability so if there are
two arms that have the same probability
and they both have the max action max
value then you would split your time
between those until the value has
changed so this is an example where if
we first sampled a1 once then sample day
two months and because there's a nonzero
probability that those samples would
make it look that action a1 has a lower
mean than action a2 then you could lock
into the wrong action forever now an e
greedy algorithm which we've seen before
in class I does something very similar
except for with probability 1 minus
Epsilon and we select the greedy action
and otherwise with epsilon we split our
probability across all the other actions
or all the other arms so in these cases
we have some more robustness so in this
case you know we would continue to
sample the other action but we're always
going to make a suboptimal decision at
least epsilon percent of the time well
approximately it's a little bit less
than that because if you do it totally
randomly not a I but its order Epsilon I
mean a it's slightly less than that
because I'm a if you uniformly split
across all your arms with one over the
number of arms probability will be
selecting the optimal action
okay so let's see these in practice for
a second before we talk more about
better algorithms so let's imagine we're
trying to figure out how to treat broken
toes and this is not a real medical
example but let's imagine there's three
different surgery at three different
options one is surgery one is buddy
taping the broken toe with another toe
which is what the internet might tell
you to do and the third is to do nothing
and the outcome measure is gonna be a
binary variable of whether or not your
toe is healed after six weeks as
assessed by an x-ray okay so let's
imagine that we model this is a
multi-armed bandit with three arms where
each arm corresponds to well I'll ask
you in a second what they corresponds to
and and there's an unknown parameter
here so each are there's an unknown
parameter which is the reward outcome so
let's just take just you know one or two
minutes just to say what does a pool of
an arm correspond to in this case and
why is it reasonable to model it as a
bandit instead of an MDP
and in terms of Lobby Mottola has
abandoned one reason is that MVPs
usually think of an agent walking
through the worlds in each the state
world it's many different states to me
analyze those here we have just one
state till is broken and various actions
it's raised it says Christ so here we
just have one day and and so what is
what is the what does it mean to pull an
arm in this case or take an action what
does that correspond to in the real
world that would be a new patient coming
in and then making a decision that they
care for that patient right so that's
like a patient coming in and the nuts
deciding to either do surgery on them or
giving them I in this case I like doing
one of the three options for treatment
and so in this case to the each pool is
a different patient so how we treat a
patient one isn't going to generally
affect how we treat patient two in terms
of whether they healed or not or whether
that particular your you know surgery
worked for them it doesn't affect the
next patient coming in so all the
patients are IID and what we want to
figure out to do is which of these
treatments on average is most effective
okay so let's think about these in a
particular set setting so a particular
set of values so let's imagine that
they're all bernoulli reward very
variables because either the toe is
gonna be healed or it's not going to be
healed after six weeks turns out in this
particular fake example surgery is best
so if you do surgery with 95%
probability it'll be healed after six
weeks
buddy taping is 90% and doing nothing is
point one so what would have
if we did something like a greedy
algorithm oh yeah great other factors
going to like pulling the arms for
example surgeries like taxing or cost
effective versus a thing either way to
incorporate that yeah it's a great
question
so I'm itchin is about like you know
could we you know surgery is a lot more
invasive than about the other side
effect success etc there's a couple
different ways you could imagine putting
that information in one of you could
just change the reward outcome so you
could say maybe it's more effective but
it's also really costly and I've got to
have some way to combine outcomes with
cost another thing that one might be
interested doing in these sorts of cases
is that you might have a distribution of
outcomes so in this case all of them
have the same distribution they're all
Bernoulli but in some cases your reward
outcomes will not be will be complicated
functions right like so it might be that
maybe for some people surgery is really
awful and for most people it's really
good but it's really bad for some people
because they have you know some really
bad side effects and so it's mean is
still better but there's like this
really bad risk tale of like maybe
people you know react badly to
anesthesia or something like that so in
those cases you might want to not focus
on expected outcomes you might want to
look at risk sensitivity and in fact one
of the things that we're doing in my
group is looking at safe reinforcement
learning including safe bandits and
thinking about how you could optimize
for risk sensitive criteria another
thing that we're not going to talk about
today which you also might want to do in
this case is that patients are not all
identical and you might want to
incorporate some sort of contextual
features about the patient to try to
decide which surgery to do or no surgery
versus buddy taping and hopefully what
those of you who are doing the default
project will think about this definitely
and we'll probably get to this in a
couple lectures so in general we often
have sort of a rich contextual state
which will also affect the outcomes okay
so in this case let's imagine that we
have these three potential interventions
that we can do and we're running the
greedy algorithm so as before we're
gonna simple each of these arms once and
now we're going to get an empirical
average so let's say that we sample
action a1 and we get a plus one and so
now our empirical average of what the
reward is for action a1 is 1 and then we
do a 2 and we also get 1 so that's our
new average and then we do a 3 we get a
0 and so at this point what is the
probability of greedy selection each arm
assuming that ties are split randomly
first to have something third one for
myself
yeah so because that is exactly correct
for the e greedy case so you're jumping
ahead a little bit but that's totally
right and in this case for greedy it'll
just be 50/50 yeah
you're already moving to equally so yeah
so the probability of a 1 is gonna equal
to probability of a 2 just gonna equal
to 1/2 so let's imagine that we did this
for a few time steps so so we can think
about what the regret is that we incur
along all of this way so at the
beginning we have this sort of
initialization period where we're gonna
select each action once and we're always
comparing this to what was the reward we
could have gotten under the optimal
action so the regret here is going to be
exactly equal so this is optimal and
remember there gret is going to be Q of
a star minus Q of the action you took so
in the first case it's going to be zero
because we took the optimal action in
the second case it's going to be point
nine five minus 0.9 which is at 0.05 and
in the third case it's gonna be 0.9 five
minus 0.1 and then in the third case
it's going to be zero or a fourth case
it's gonna be zero and then it's going
to be 0.05 again now in this situation
will we ever select in greedy will we
ever select a three again given the
values we've seen so far
no yeah I see people will say yeah no so
why not
is it possible what's our current
estimate of the reward for a t30 yeah so
I guess I didn't show put those here but
this was the actual these were the
rewards we got so it was 1 1 0 so our
current estimate for a 3 is 0 we know
our rewards are bounded between 0 & 1
none of our estimates can ever collapse
below zero and we already have a
positive 1
for these other two actions which means
that their averages can never go to zero
so we're never gonna take a 3 again now
in this case that's not actually that
bad like here here that's not actually a
problem because a 3 is a bad arm and
it's got a much lower expected reward in
other cases I it could be that a 3 we
just got unlucky and in that case it
could mean that we never should never
take the optimal action and that's the
same as this good question so this is
the same as B star yeah and I'll go back
and forth between notation but yeah
definitely just ask me so in this case
we're never gonna select a 3 again and
now notice that in the greedy case there
are cases where if I had used slightly
different values here that you might
have selected a 3 again later because if
it's the case that like if you didn't
have Bernoulli rewards but you had
Gaussian x' it could be that the rewards
for other arms drop below another arm
later and then you start to switch so
you don't necessarily always stick with
which other arm look best at the
beginning but in this particular case
with these outcomes then you're not kind
of like a 3 ever again all right now
let's do a greedy so in this case we're
gonna assume we got exactly the same
outcomes for the first few and then what
that is that we're gonna have I 1/2
minus epsilon over 2 so we're gonna
split ties randomly again so
probability Epsilon we're gonna take
with epsilon over 3 we're going to take
a 1 or a 2 or a 3 and with 1 minus
epsilon over 2 we're gonna take a 1 or a
2 interesting ok so in this case it's
gonna look almost identical except we're
still gonna have some probability of
taking a 3 in this case and we can do a
similar computation here in this case
we've assumed that all of these are
exactly the same so II greedy in this
case we'll select a 3 again yes if
epsilon is fixed not updating it if
epsilon is fixed how many times is it
going to select a 3 main question is
whether it's finite or infinite so maybe
talk to a neighbor first I can I decide
whether if epsilon is fixed whether
it'll be a 3 will be selected a finite
or infinite number of times and what
that means in terms of the regret
okay I'm gonna have everybody vote so if
you think it's gonna be selected an
infinite number of times raise your hand
great so what's that mean in terms of
regret is the regret gonna be good or
bad great I mean in general regrets
gonna be unbounded unfortunately in
these cases so we're always going to
unfortunately have infinite regret but
but the rate at which it grows can be it
can be much smaller depending on the
algorithm you do so in particular and I
yeah so we can also think about it in
this case so if you have a large gap
which we do free a three here and we're
gonna be selecting that arm an infinite
number of times then a greedy is also
gonna have a large regret so I like this
plot this plot comes from David Silver's
slides so if you explore forever like if
you just do random which we didn't
discuss but you could also do then
you're gonna have linear total regret
which means that with a number of time
steps T you're gonna scale linearly with
T essentially your regret is going
unbounded Lee and it's growing linearly
which is essentially proportional I mean
it's gonna generally have a constant in
front of it but it's gonna be constant
times the worst you could do it every
time step because if you always select
the worst arm and every time step your
regret will also grow linearly so it's
pretty bad
if you explore never if you do greedy
then it also can be linear and if you do
eat greedy it's also linear so
essentially it means that all of these
algorithms that we've been using so far
can have really really bad performance
certainly in bad cases and so the
critical question is whether or not it's
better it's possible to be better than
that so can we have some what's often
called sub linear regret so we want to
have regret if an algorithms gonna be
considered good in terms of its
performance and its sample efficiency
we're gonna want its regret to grow sub
linearly
when we think about this we're generally
going to think about whether the bounds
that we create and the performance
bounds are going to be problem
independent or problem dependent so most
of the bounds it depends a little bit
for MDPs most of the bounds that we can
get are going to be problem independent
for bandits there's a lot of problem
dependent bounds problem dependent
bounds in the case of bandits mean that
the amount of regret that we get is
gonna be a function of those gaps and
that should be sort of intuitive so if
you have let's imagine that we just have
two arms like a one and a two and the
mean expected reward so if this is the
expect or worn is 1 and this is
suspected or two point zero zero one two
ative Li it should be easier to figure
out that arm one is better than arm two
then if this is like point five three
and this is 0.5 to 5 here's a one case
really hard to tell the difference
between the mean of the two arms and the
other case that means a really really
far apart so somewhat intuitively if the
gap is really large it should be easier
for us to learn and if it's really small
it should be harder yeah good question
and if the optimal are if the optimal
reward is you just same optimal reward
yes the optimal or reward is
deterministic too we have zero regret if
you know it so if you know that all the
rewards of the arms are deterministic
then you just need to pull them once
then you can make a good decision to
that you're done in general these
algorithms aren't going to know that
information if you don't even if it was
deterministic you're still going to have
these other forms of bounds if it's
Tournament if in the greedy place it's a
good question in the greedy case if your
real rewards are deterministic then only
then you would have pulled all arms once
and you will make no mistakes
you'll make you'll have zero regret
basically from that point onwards so
we'd consider that is just like you'd
have some initial constant regret and
then afterward it would be independent
of teeth did you have question is it
also a function of audience oh yeah
great question so we're not gonna talk
question is whether also depends on the
very institution to the mean yes we're
not going to talk about that but in
addition to problem dependent bounds you
could certainly think about parametric
like if you have some parametric
knowledge on the distribution of the
rewards then you can exploit it so if
you know it's a Gaussian or other things
like that
I think in general if you know the mo
like if you have information about the
moments then you should be able to
exploit it most the information I've
seen is I'm looking at the mean in the
variance we very frequently throughout a
lot of this stuff is art gonna assume
that our rewards are bounded that's
gonna be important for most of the
proofs that we do even without making
any other parametric assumptions okay
but then the other version of this is
problem independent which just says
regardless of the domain you're in and
regardless of the gaps can we also show
that I regardless of any structure of
the problem can we still ensure that the
regret grows sub linearly and that's
what we're gonna most ly focus on today
so I think lower about lower theoretical
bounds are hopeful to try to understand
how hard a problem is so I said is it
possible for something to be sub linear
and there's been previous work to look
at sort of well how much does the regret
have to grow so in this case this is
regret we're mostly going to use right
out regret but in this case they prove
that in terms of the gaps and the
similarity and the distributions in
terms of the KL divergence the KL
divergence that you can show a lower
bound on how much regret grows so this
is where the sort of unfortunate aspect
of regret growing boundedly comes up if
you don't make any other assumptions on
the distributions of your rewards right
in general the regret of your your
regret will go unbounded Lee and it will
do so in terms of these gaps and the KL
divergence but it's still sub linear so
that's nice
so it's growing logarithmically with T
here T is the time steps
I think regime that like our lower
bounds suggest that there's room for
traction right that we can definitely at
least there's no formal result that says
it has to be linear it says no we should
be able to grow much slower so how could
we how would we maybe do this so this is
now we've talked about a particular
framework which is regret we talked
about a setting which has banned it so
now we're going to talk about an
approach which is optimism in the face
of uncertainty and the idea is simply to
choose actions which might have high
value why should we do this sorry is
that true at every T or only in the
women because as it's written isn't that
just saying that it's greater than
infinity ah that's a good question
question is about whether it holds I
think this holds on every time stuff I'd
have to check the exact like way that
they wrote this there's also constants
but I think this should hold on a per
time step basis yeah the limit as to
those large this is where I have to look
back at the original paper
there's probably additional constant
terms which are transitory and so this
is probably the dominant term as T goes
large but in a lot of the regret bounds
particularly in our MDP cases we often
have transitory terms that are
independent of the time step but are
still large early on that's my guess but
great question
okay so optimism in the face of
uncertainty says that we should choose
actions that might have a high value why
well there's two possible outcomes if we
pick something that we think might be
good one is it's good
so if it is good I'll be more precise in
this case let's say we select so a 1 and
1 is a 1 has high reward so that's good
if we if we took an action it actually
does it a we cuz we thought it might
have high reward and actually does have
high reward then we're gonna have small
regret that's good what's the other
outcome a 1 does not have high reward
huh as lower as when we sample this we
get our our a 1 with low reward well if
we get something with low reward we've
learned something so we're like hey you
know we tried that restaurant again we
thought it was great the first time the
second time it was horrible so now we've
learned that that restaurant is not as
good and we update our estimate of how
good that restaurant is and that means
we don't think that that action has as
high a value as it did before
so essentially either the world really
is great and that in which case that's
great we're gonna have low regret or the
world is not that great and then we
learn something so this give us
information and so this be acting
optimistically gives us both information
into the bow of the world or allows us
to achieve high reward and so it turns
out to have been a really nice principle
it's been around since at least Leslie
cabling in 1993 introduced this idea of
sort of interval estimation and then
they're starting to be a lot of analysis
of these types of optimism under
uncertainty techniques so how could we
do this more formally or like we're
would we get to be more precise about
what it means for an action to have a
high value let's imagine that we
estimate an upper confidence bound for
each action value such that the real
value of that action is less than or
equal to the upper confidence bound with
high probability
and those upper confidence bounds and
generally going to depend on how many
times we've selected that particular
action because we would like it to be
such that if we've sliced at that action
a lot that upper confidence bound should
be pretty close to Q of eight and if we
haven't selected it very much maybe
we're really optimistic and then we can
define an upper confidence bound bandit
algorithm by just selecting whichever
action has the highest upper confidence
bound so for every single action we
maintain an upper confidence bound and
then we just select which everyone has
the max and then we update the upper
confidence bound for that action after
we take it so a UCB algorithm would for
T equals one dot you would first have an
initialization phase where we pull it
charm once a charm once and then we
compute UT of 88 and then for T equals
one dot we would select 80 equally miss
Arg max and then we would get a reward
that is sampled from the true reward
distribution for that arm and then we
would update UT of 80 and all other arms
turns out that often we have to update
not just the action of the arm that we
took for the action of all the other
arms we took - and this basically comes
in - you don't have to do that but in
terms of the theory we often have to do
that in order to account for high
probability bouts and we'll see more
about that in just a second so every
time you get a reward you update the
upper confidence bounds of all your arms
and then you select the next action and
you repeat this just over and over again
okay so how are we going to define these
U of T so we're gonna use hoppings
inequality
the refresher in hoppings inequality we
can apply this to a set of iid random
variables we're going to assume right
now that all of them are bounded between
0 & 1 and we're gonna define our sample
mean just to be the average over all of
those variables and then what hop ting
says is that the probability that that
expected mean is like this is the true
expected mean so this is the true mean
this is our empirical mean and this is
you think of this as like some Epsilon
this is just some constant is the
probability that your true mean is
greater than the empirical mean plus
some constant U is less than or equal to
X the exponential minus 2 n mu squared
so this is the number of samples we have
so we can also invert this to say if you
want this to be true with a certain
probability you can pick a mu so that xn
plus mu is going to be at least as large
as that the real mean so let's say what
we want to do is we want that this two
we want that the empirical mean plus mu
the probability that that's less than
the real mean 2 equal to Delta over T
squared and we'll see why we might want
to choose that particular probability
shortly but let's imagine for a second
that's what we want our probability to
be since then we can solve for what Mew
has to be okay so that's exponential
minus 2 n mu squared has to equal to
Delta over T squared and then what we do
is we just solve for what mu is thanks
for letting me know so mu in this case
is going to be equal to the square root
1 over 2 n log of T squared over Delta
so I just saw
that equation what does that tell us
that says that if we do predefined our
UT of or in this case we define I'll
keep with the same notation as opting so
if we have X and plus mu with that
particular choice of mu that's generally
going to be greater than or equal to the
true expected value of X with
probability greater than equal to one
minus Delta over T squared so this
hop-tsya equality gives us a way to
define an upper bound because instead of
these mean X's right now you could
imagine those are just pools from our
arm and those are all rewards and so
this says if you take your empirical
average of your rewards so far and you
add in this upper bound which depends on
the number of times we pulled that arm
and T so T here notice is the total
number of time steps we pulled any arms
and n is the number of times we pulled
that arm so they're not the same thing
so we're inside of this confidence bound
we have a confidence bound that is
decreasing at a rate of how many times
we pulled this particular arm and then
we have a log term which is increasing
at the rate of the number of times we
pulled any arm and that is the reason
why after each time step we have to
update the upper confidence bounds of
all the arms so you kind of have these
two competing rates that are going on as
you pull an arm more you're gonna get a
better estimate of its reward so it's
shrinking but then you also have this
slower growing term this log which is
increasing with the number of time steps
all right so this is one way we could
define our for confidence bouts so we
could use this in the case of our
rewards so we might want to say that UT
of 80 is equal to our empirical average
of that arm plus 1 over 2 the number of
times we pulled that arm times log of T
squared divided by Delta
so this is how one way for us to define
our upper confidence bounds all right so
now the next question is okay so we've
done that how is that going to help us
in terms of showing that maybe the
regret of something which is optimistic
is actually sublinear okay so what we're
gonna do now is I'll do a quick poll do
you guys want me to write it on here do
you guys want me to do it on the board
so raise your hand if you want it on the
board all right where's your hand if you
want it on here okay we'll do this next
part on the board that was easy was
there Chris in the back in this
derivation about G because it seems like
he first introduced it about T yes first
introduced it it was basically constant
that we moved around but then later
you're saying if that's actually the
time that we're updating every time so
so how are we able to do that yeah it's
a good so um you're right and I mean
slightly impervious ice about this if
you know what the time horizon is that
you're gonna be acting in an abandoned
you can set T to be the maximum so you
if you know that you're gonna act for T
time steps you can plug that in and then
your confidence bounds are then that log
term is fixed basically in online
settings if you don't know that you can
also constantly be an updated with the
time step it's a good question yeah what
is Delta so freshmen is what is Delta
and what we're gonna I did not tell you
in this kit well in this case it's
telling us it's specifying what is the
probability this is holding like what
this inequality is holding later we're
gonna provide a regret bound that is
high probability so we're gonna say
about which is something like with
probabilities one minus a function of
Delta you're regret will be sub linear
so that's you can get expected regret
bounds two and the UCB paper which one
of the original UCB papers provides an
expected bound but I thought it was a
little the this bound was a little bit
easier to do in class so I thought I
would do with a high probability Bob
yeah
talking about regret I didn't exactly
understand how you use regret to update
your estimate of the action value Oh
question so profession is do be use or
how do would we use the regret bound to
regret to update our estimate action we
don't regret is just a tool to analyze
our algorithm great clarification so
regret is a way for the rest to analyze
whether or not an algorithm is going to
be good or bad in terms of how fast the
regret grow it grows but it's not used
in the algorithm itself the algorithm
doesn't compute regret I mean it's not
used in terms of the updating excuse me
okay so I should I'll leave this one up
here so you guys can continue to see
that all right so let's do our proof so
what we're gonna want to do now is we're
gonna want to try to prove something
about the regret but before and and how
quickly it grows for the upper
confidence bound algorithm but before I
prove that I'm gonna try to argue to you
that we're gonna look at sort of the
probability of failure of these regrets
out of these confidence bounds so what
I've said here is that and we're gonna
define these upper confidence bounds
like this in terms of the empirical mean
for that arm so far plus this term that
depends on the number of times we pull
that arm and what I want to convince you
now is what is the probability what is
the probability that on one step that on
some step step the confidence bounds
will fail to hold confidence bounds will
fail to hold why is this bad okay so we
want to bound the probability that on
any step excuse me as we're running our
algorithm that our confidence bounds
fail to hold why because if they all
hold we can guarantee we're gonna be
making some we're gonna have some nice
properties okay so note if all the
confidence bounds hold like
on every step and we can ensure the
following so if all comrades hold ball
up bounce hold then UT of 80 this is the
actual arm we selected is going to be
greater than Q of a star the real value
the real value of the optimal arm okay
so why is this true there's two cases
here either a T is equal to a star or a
T is not equal to a star so let's just
take a second to maybe talk to your
neighbor to say if it's the case that
our confidence bound hold which means
that really is the case that we have UT
we that this confidence bound is gonna
be greater than equal to the meet for
that arm so these are true confidence
bounds this equation is holding we're
not getting there failure so we know
that QT which is this is going to be
greater than the real expected value for
that arm okay so if that's true then
this is gonna hold it every time step so
maybe let's take a neighbor if it's not
clear what I'm asking or how to think
about that feel free to raise your hand
too so there's two cases either the arm
that we selected is a star there are
more you selected is not a star and in
both cases this is going to hold if the
confidence bounds are correct
so maybe let's take a second to think
about this or feel free to raise your
hand if it's not clear how to how to get
started on that let me just be clear
here so
I just wanted to note at the top there
that if the confidence bounds hold then
that upper confidence bounds which is
equal to that is going to be greater
than the real expected value for that
arm yep on the conference written over
there so you're saying that the optimal
like your optimal Q value should be less
than all the confidence bounds for any
action so just me declare if I would say
this is saying for the arm that you
selected the upper confidence bound of
the arm you selected is has a value that
that upper confidence bound that you use
to choose the arm
whichever arm you selected the upper
confidence amount of that arm is a
higher than the true value of the
optimal arm that's what this is this
equation is saying saying that if the
confidence bounce hold on all time steps
they might not but let's say that they
do because these are only high
probability bounds but if they hold on
all time steps then whatever arm you
selected its upper confidence bound is
higher than the value of the true arm
the real value is that your arm and I
just wanted to be clear what I mean for
the confidence bound to hold I put this
up there so that means that the upper
confidence founder of an arm holding
means that that upper confidence bound
which is defined in that way is greater
than the true value of that arm so let's
work through this a little bit so let's
see there's two cases so
if 80 is equal to a star then that's
what this is saying is that saying is is
UT of a star greater than QM a star does
that hold of the confidence bounds hold
yes by definition so if you look up
there so the upper confidence bounds if
it holds for an action for that the
upper confidence bound for an action has
to be bigger than the mean for that
action if that upper competence bounds
hold okay so this how this works so if
we really selected the optimal action
we've defined our upper confidence
bounds that they really are better than
the mean of that arm and so this is
holds the other case is that a T is not
equal to a star so what does that mean
that means that UT of a T is greater
than u T of a star because otherwise we
would have selected a star it means that
some other arm had a higher upper
confidence bound than the optimal action
and we know that this is greater than Q
of a star
okay so if the confidence bounds holds
we know it every single time step the
upper confidence bound of the arm we
selected is better than the true mean of
the optimal arm yes so I don't pull your
question yet in this case maximizing
action I know u T so this only holds
this part only holds because we're
picking that Arg max you're not going to
see this but the Arg max a of u T of 18
so that first inequality only well there
might be other algorithms a hold for two
but it holds in particular for the upper
competence bound great great question
okay so this says if we could get it and
we'll see shortly why that matters but
kind of intuitively this says if the
confidence bounds hold then we know that
super confidence bound of the arm we
select is going to be better than the
optimal arm and the reason we're gonna
want that is later when we're doing the
regret bounds we do not want to deal
with properties we don't observe namely
the value of the optimal arm because we
don't know what Q of a star is okay we
don't know which arm it is so when we
look at regret down right now regret
bounds are in terms of Q of a star we
don't know what that quantity is so
we're gonna need to figure out some way
to get rid of that quantity and we're
gonna end up using the these upper
bounds but we're gonna need the fact
that the upper bound of the arm we
select is better than the Q star Q of a
star okay so so this is saying that
that's true if our upper confidence
bounds hold what is the probability that
that occurs okay
so what that means is if we want to say
that on all time steps this is a union
bout this is a union over events
the Union over all the events 40 equals
1/2 teeth of the probability that Q of a
star minus the upper confidence bound at
the action that we took we want this
oops that way you want the probability
of this which is essentially the
probability of failure so this is what's
the product we this is if all confidence
bounds hold things are good it says what
is the probability that that failed that
the arm that you took it actually is not
better the upper confidence bound is not
better than the real mean of the optimal
arm so this is the failure case where
the confidence met and we're gonna say
that if we look at that we don't want
this thing to happen we can upper bound
that by making sure our upper confidence
bounds hold at all time steps so these
are the arms what I said up there is
that if all of our confidence bounds
hold on all time steps we can ensure
that so we're now going to write that
down in terms of what's the probability
that the upper confidence bounds do hold
on all time steps and so we're gonna do
probability that Q of 80s Q hat of 80 is
greater than you okay
this is the upper confidence bound we
defined over there this is just saying
that the upper confidence bound holds
for each arm on each time step well by
definition over there we said we we
picked an upper confidence bound to make
sure this held with least probability of
Delta over T squared because that's how
we defined our upper confidence bound we
picked a big enough thing to add on to
our empirical means so that we could
ensure that that upper confidence bound
really was larger than our mean so now
we have a Union over all time steps a
Union over all arms Delta divided by T
squared and note that if you sum over T
equals one to infinity
of T to the minus T that's equal to PI
squared over 6 which is less than 2 so
when you do this sum you get 2 m Delta
so what this says is that the
probability that your upper confidence
bounds hold over all time steps so this
is the negative this is that they that
they don't hold is at least 1 minus 2 m
Delta so we're all our what we're gonna
end up doing is we're gonna have a high
probability regret found that says with
probability at least 1 minus 2 m Delta
you're gonna get a small regret yeah
great question yes this is all for an
infinite horizon case we're gonna look
at the we're gonna find our regret in
terms of T the number of time steps all
right so why is this useful do you guys
want me to leave this up or we can move
that now everyone's written it down who
wants it
okay so let's can this go up Macey
we're not okay so why is this useful
okay we're now gonna define our regret
so this part of the board just says that
we've made it so these upper confidence
bounds holds with high probability now
we're gonna try to show what our regret
is going to be oh good
okay thank you all right so what's our
regret regret of our UCP algorithm after
tea time steps it's just equal to the
sum over all those time steps T equals
1/2 T of Q of a star minus Q okay
remember we don't know either of these
things we don't know what the real mean
is of any arm we pick and we don't know
what the real mean is at the optimal arm
so we need to turn this into things that
we know these are unknown so what we're
going to do is one of our favorite
tricks in reinforcement learning which
is we add and subtract the same thing so
we do some overt equal minus T equals 1
to T of u T this upper bound 80 minus Q
of 80 plus Q of a star minus u T 80 I
just added and subtracted the same thing
I picked the upper confidence bound of
the arm that we selected at each time
point so then the important thing is
that what we showed over here is that if
all of our confidence bounds hold then
the upper confidence bound of the arm we
selected is larger than Q of a star
that's what we showed over there so that
means that this has to be less than or
equal to 0
use the upper confidence bound of
whatever arm we selected we proved over
there is going to be higher than the
real mean of the optimal arm so this
second part of this equation is less
than or equal to 0 which means we can
upper bound our regret as follows so now
we can drop that second term so that's
nice right because now we don't have any
a stars anymore we only are looking at
the actions that we actually took at
each time step and we're comparing the
upper confidence bounded e at that time
steps versus the real mean
but remember the way we've defined our
upper confidence bound and put it over
here the way we defined our upper
confidence bound UT of 80 is exactly
equal to the empirical mean 80 plus this
square root 1 over 2 + 80 log t squared
over Delta and we said here that this
was going to be the difference from HOF
ting between Q of 80 minus Q hat
so the probability that this remember I
called this you the probability that
this was greater than mu was small so
now we're assuming that all of our
confidence bounds hold which means that
we know that the difference between the
real empirical mean and the true mean of
this arm is bounded by you yeah see um
two questions first of all where is this
second so you have a Union over I equals
one of them for arms I don't see where
that index actually factors in and then
also if you could just go over the third
line with the belt over T squared in
summation how we derive that sure yes so
so what we did there is we said that if
are you asking about the second line to
the third line yes so what we did that
in this case is we said for each it we
want to make sure that on each of the
time steps all of the upper confidence
bounds hold and so that's where we get
an additional sum over here over all the
arms so this is conservative trying to
make sure we don't know you could
imagine just doing this over the arm
that's selected but we don't know which
arm is selected we want to be able to
show is this is going to be a looser
upper upper bound saying this is
sufficient so we're saying that if you
want to make sure that Q of a star
greater than the upper bound of the arm
that is selected it is sufficient to
ensure that your upper confidence bounds
are valid at all time points from this
from this reasoning up here and so this
is the probability that your upper
confidence bounds are correct on all
times points for every single time point
for every single arm your upper
confidence bounds have to hold and then
what we get in this case is we said that
the probability on a particular time
step the upper confidence bounds holds
is Delta over T squared that's how we
defined that you term so that according
to Houghton's inequality it would hold
with at least probability dealt over T
squared and then so this is that and
then I just made a side note that this
is not something some of you guys might
have seen this but I certainly wouldn't
expected people to that just it turns
out that in terms of the limit if you
sum over T equals 1 to infinity of T to
the minus 2 that's bounded by PI squared
over 6 which is less than 2 fun fact
so so you can plug that in right because
then you just get a 2 here and then you
just get a sum over all arms which is M
and you have a delta so this just allows
us to take it take that infinite sum so
notice also that this goes to question
before this holds for the infinite
horizon because when we did this summing
we're basically making sure that our
confidence bounds hold forever ok great
so we said here now that we're doing all
of this part under the assumption that
our confidence bounds hold our
confidence bounds hold mean that the
difference between our expected mean and
the true mean for that same arm is
bounded by Mew bounded by you with high
probability where this is the definition
of you so that's what our hosting
inequality allowed us to stay so take
that quantity now that's ru and plug it
in here so this is looking exactly the
difference between our upper confidence
bound and Q so this is exactly equal to
sum over T equals 1/2 T of U it's a
little confusing in terms of notation so
I'll just plug in the exact
expression right there 1 over 2 NT of 80
so we've just plugged in that the
difference between the empirical mean
and the true mean is bounded by its
quantity you okay all right so then in
this case what we can do is we can split
this up into the different arms that we
pulled okay so this is a sum over all
time steps we can pull out
note that this is if we upper bound this
by Big T this is equal to less than or
equal to square root log Big T squared
over Delta and then we're gonna get a
sum over all time steps and we're going
to split this up according to which arms
we selected okay so for this is the same
as if we look at for each of the arms
how many times did we pull it so sum
over N equals one to n TI square root 1
over n so we just divided this up like
for each of the arms we selected them
some amount of times that's here I as I
is indexing our arms so n TI is the
total number of times we selected arm I
and then we sum that up and then
if we note the fact that if you sum from
N equals one to T square root one over n
that is less than or equal to two square
root T you use an integral argument for
that and I'm happy to talk about it
offline
Thanks
I'll be a little loose with constants
that definitely catch them because most
of these bounds will all add up being
about whether it's sub linear linear
let's get to be precise okay so we have
this quantity here when is this quantity
maximized this quantity is gonna be
maximized if we pulled all arms an equal
number of times
why because 1 over N is decreasing with
n and so the the largest these can be is
if you split if you split your pools
across all arms equally so if we go back
up to here and I call this a so a is
gonna be less than or equal to excuse me
square root 1/2 log T squared over Delta
times sum over I equals 1 to M sum over
N equals 1 to T divided by M so this is
as if we split all of our pools equally
across all the arms 1 over squared + and
then we can use this expression okay so
this is less than or equal to 1 over 2
we're almost there T squared over Delta
and then we're gonna get some over I
equals 1 to M of 2
square root to your ab okay and then
when you sum this over M get less than
or equal to square root 1 over 2 log T
squared over a delta that brings an M
into there bring it like another 2 in
here times T and now we're done so what
does this shown this is shown that if we
use our competence bounds that the rate
at which our regret grows is sub-linear
square root times a log so T here is the
number of time stamps so time steps so
as if we are if we use our competence
bounce in order to make our decisions
then the regret grows much slower this
is a problem independent bound it
doesn't depend on the gaps there's much
there's much nicer ones and tighter ones
that depend on the gaps but this
indicates why optimism is fundamentally
as a sound thing to do in the case of
bandits is that allows us to grow much
it allows us to have much better
performance in terms of regret than it
does for the equity case long term here
T equals a is ranging from T equals 1 to
T this long term is maximized when T is
big T so we're upper bounding that log
term and then it becomes a constant we
can pull it out so the cool thing here
is that this is sublinear that's that
that's really the main point well I go
through an example and we'll go through
more of this next time I go we next go
through an example for the toy domain
for the broken toes of like what do
these upper confidence bounds look like
in that case and then what will the
algorithm do in these scenarios so
that's what we'll look at next and then
after that we'll look at so this is
where one class of take
Meek's which is this optimism under
uncertainty approach which is saying
that we're gonna look at what the value
is based on a combination of the
empirical rewards we've seen so far plus
an upper confidence bound over them and
use that to make decisions and then the
next thing we'll see too is where we are
Bayesian about the world and we instead
maintain a prior and we update our prior
and use that to figure out how to act so
we'll go through this next weekend and
I'll see them